happy birthday adil  so uh adil has been my programmer for  the last little while  and he's creating all sorts of great new  initiatives and new projects  for the website for my business whenever  you know i come up with an idea of  something i want to create  i can just give a deal and he will  execute and  uh that's an awesome luxury to have and  what i love about a deal is how much he  loves  helping people loves entrepreneurs and  the passion he brings  he's excited about the projects we're  working on he comes up with ideas  he's working till whatever it's  sometimes eight in the morning  working all night overnight till late in  the morning and and  uh a deal i just love the energy passion  you bring i hope you have a great year  happy birthday from from myself from the  entire team  and this next clip is for you happy  birthday  to you happy birthday  to you happy birthday  dear adil  happy birthday to you  you